[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir ce soir je voudrais vous parler
de la prise de parole en public
je vous avoue que c'est un
sujet avec lequel je suis pas très à
l'aise en réalité parce que je m'accorde
très peu de thé légimité
légitimité en raison de mon bégaiement
et pourtant il n'ya pas très longtemps
j'ai remporté un concours d'éloquence
je m'appelle samira je suis assistante
sociale
mon métier c'est d'écouter les gens
toute la journée je les écoute pour les
aider à conscientiser
et à mettre en action leur potentiel
afin d'atteindre l'autonomie à laquelle
ils aspirent
j'analyse avec eux les petits
les difficultés qu'ils rencontrent dans
leur quotidien au regard de
l'environnement dans lequel ils évoluent
regarde de la personne qu'ils sont et
des ressources qui leur sont propres
dans mon métier
l'écoutent est probablement l'une des
qualités les plus importantes à
développer
savoir écouter que quelqu'un
savoir se taire
pour offrir à l'autre un espace de
parole tout en restant totalement
investi dans l'instant
c'est proposer à l'autre un
climat de bienveillance sincère et une
attention indispensable à la mise en
cours confiance
toute la journée j'écoute les autres
être ce qu'ils sont et l'exprimé à voix
haute je les écoute parler de
entre eux et aux autres
ça je je sais faire et après seize
années d'exercice professionnel je peux
vous dire que je maîtrise parfaitement
la compétence doute que les gouttes
d'ailleurs je la maîtrise tellement que
lorsque j'ai tout sur mon avenir
professionnel
et que je me demande qu'est ce que je
pourrais faire d'autre
un jour
je me rends compte que je ne sais rien
faire d'autre que d'écouter les gens
et d'ailleurs si je regarde en arrière
je je réalise que j'ai été bien plus un
être de silence qu un être de parole
est pourtant
passé du silence à l'expression orale et
le cheminement naturel de l'homme le
foetus est silencieux tout au long de
son séjour dans le ventre et il
s'exprime bruyamment dès la naissance
pour le plus jamais ça
c'est parler
d'ailleurs en
1989 où il ya bhl levett l'a très bien
expliqué
par les nôtres occupation préférée
nous passons des heures entières à
discuter à raconter une histoire
à débattre argumenter et même à nous
parler à nous mêmes
mais au final qu'est ce que la parole
la parole c'est l'utilisation de la
langue qu un individu fait de façon
totalement individuel et
singulière elle le revers des
caractéristiques variées le ton employé
le vocabulaire la
prononciation le débit le volume de la
voix etc
la parole a aussi la caractéristique
d'évoluer avec les époques et les
sociétés alors que l'être humain respire
de la même manière depuis des
millénaires notre parole ne
cesse de se
modifier et d'évoluer au fil du temps
la parole à des fonctions très diverses
la première c'était là une fosse aux
fonctions expressive
nous utilisons la papa parole pour
exprimer une idée une pensée
ressenti un cri de joie ou de peur un
murmure de tendresse
la parole a aussi une fonction
communicante et
socialisante elle est le moyen qu'a
trouvé l'homme pour entrer en
interaction avec l'autre pour échanger
avec lui et partager
la parole ne peut s'acquérir d'ailleurs
que par l'interaction humaine ce qui
n'est pas le cas des autres fonctions
humaines
enfin la parole a selon moi une
caractéristique
et de fonctions d'identification
je vous ai dit un petit peu avant que la
parole était singulière et personnel
elle révèle notre identité
elle est un élément constitutif de notre
identité
la parole que vous allez prendre
selon qu'elle soit
avec de nous voir franche ou hésitante
un vocabulaire riche ou pauvre va vous
placez dans un certain nombre de groupes
sociaux qui vont vous identifié comme un
père
ma parole à moi et
saccadé elle est haché et elle est
pleine de blocage
elle n'est pas fluide comme celle des
autres speaker
et vous pouvez entendre
que je bloque sur les mots que
je répète certains sont de façon
incontrôlée et vous pouvez aussi
entendre ma voix qui varient de façon
parfois in app hop
inappropriée
et vous pouvez même entendre la fatigue
physique que génère pour moi la prise de
parole en public
je ne peux pas exprimer de façon libre
et spontané ce que je ressens ou ce que
je veux en raison de mon bégaiement
c'est un handicap
alors pas de panique on n'en meurt pas
tout va bien on vit avec
effectivement on her pas du hand du
bégaiement par contre pour les personnes
qui le jeu subissent au quotidien et
général isolement parce que le
bégaiement est plus insidieux qui ne
laisse à savoir c'est un iceberg dont
les ravages
sous marins sont insoupçonnées
pour moi comme probablement pour toutes
les personnes atteintes par le trouble
chaque blocage
est un échec une capacité qui va laisser
des traces
chaque jour en moyenne vous et moi
donc prenons sont quinze mille mots par
jour
essayer de
visualiser tous les moments de votre
journée du matin jusqu'au soir
vous avez pris la parole pour parler de
tout et de rien quinze mille mots
et bien dites vous que pour moi ce sont
autant de
deux situations de deux mises en échec
mais internet échec parce que lorsque je
veux
prononcer un mot un blocage mais
n'empêche
et mise en échec aussi parce que pour
éviter un blocage je vais devoir adopter
des stratégies de contournement
par exemple je ne vais pas utiliser le
mot qui exprime parfaitement ma pensée
mais je vais en prendre un autre qui
l'expriment moins bien mais dans lequel
je ne bloquerait pas
ça peut aussi être le fait de ne pas
affirmer mon opposition parce que ça va
devoir m'obliger à argumenter et donc à
augmenter la charge émotionnelle
et donc
générer un petit peu plus de blocage et
ça peut aussi être de limiter mes
interactions humaines et mes prises de
parole
voilà quoi comment se passe le processus
de mise en échec j'ai une idée
une émotion ressentie à exprimer
j'ai envie de l'exprimer au besoin de
l'exprimer je prends la parole et je
bloque
immédiatement je me sens en échec et je
perds confiance en mes capacités
ceci va abîmer les styles de deux mois
et peu à peu je vais éviter de prendre
la parole en public pour pas me
retrouver dans la situation
et ainsi de suite
voilà le processus par lequel le
bégaiement prive très tôt les gens de
tout ce qui constitue le lead de
l'autonomisation lacroix confiance en
ses capacités et l'estiment
2,2 soit
se construire autour d'un échec
s'est érodée chaque jour un petit peu
plus la valeur que l'on s'accorde face
aux autres qui eux affichent une
communication qui toujours plus fluide
plus percutante plus éloquente plus
juste
voilà
comment on se
perd dans le
silence tr
je me tais parce que je me dis que si
mes mots ne sont pas correctement
articulé
comment est ce que l'autre va faire
l'effort de tendre l'oreille pour
entendre moment mais certains messages
comment est ce que l'autre va percevoir
ma parole et me personne recevoir
la perception c'est exactement cela
c'est
l'interprétation que fait notre système
cérébral d'une information captée par
nos sens
l'interprétation est subjectif et cette
puissance de frappe est redoutable
mon
cerveau a perçu et perçoit encore ma
parole comme un danger à
chaque fois que j'ouvre la bouche j'ai
la
sensation
irrationnelle et en même temps réel que
je suis en danger
il
rationnel parce que évidemment je vais
pas mourir mais réelle parce que mon
estime de moi et encore une fois est
rodé et donc je suis bien en
danger
alors pour me protéger du danger
naturellement j'ai trouvé refuge dans le
silence
et pour continuer à m'exprimer tout en
gardant le silence
j'ai compensé la rareté de mes mots
parlés par l'abondance de mes mots
écrits
sauf que
la vie est parfois plus audacieuse et
plus surprenantes comme l'envisagent
un peu comme
ces rues de paris
qui dévoile un paradis insoupçonnées
derrière une porte d'entrée ordinaire
alors dans ma vie ordinaire d'assistante
sociale qui écoute les autres
en 2012 21 j'ai rencontré le coin
concours tu te l'éloquence du bégaiement
ce concours au nord la parole
ce qui s'en prive
en y participant
j ai affronté le sujet de ma vie mon
bégaiement sa place dans mes mots dans
mes silences et dans mes choix de vie
pour la première fois j'ai évoqué
publiquement mes envies d'interaction
humaine et de prise de parole mais aussi
mais mes émotions mais vulnérabilité
et mes souffrances
et sans que je ne m'y attende
cette
finale dans un grand théâtre parisien
a été bon pour moi la réalisation
personnelle de ma vie celle qui m'a
affranchi du regarde
dégradée que je porte sur moi et qui m'a
en fin de compte des pour passer pour
faire écho
chez les autres
sans que je ne m'en rende compte
ce soir là j'ai renversé mon schéma de
pensée et j'ai gravé en moi ce message
ton message est plus important que des
blocages
des mots abîmé
révèle des boues pensée
puissante
peut les exprimer et les partager elle
s'intéresse et
s'inspire
ce soir là j'ai réalisé qu'en
plus de lait coûte j'avais aussi la
qualité d'être éloquente
nos
potentiels ne sont limitées que par les
zergs que l'on se met la perception
encore
alors si vous lui
permettez j'aimerais vous demander de
prendre quelques secondes pour réfléchir
à ce qui vous effraie le plus dans votre
vie
quel est l'élément de votre histoire au
bout de votre
personnalité qui vous rend le plus
vulnérables socialement et que vous
cherchez à un masque et à tout prix aux
yeux des autres
quel est votre iceberg à vous et en fin
de compte n'êtes vous pas plus
puissant que lui
ce soir
j'ai prononcé
1620 mot pour vous raconter mon histoire
1620 raison que de ne surtout pas
prendre la parole
1620 situation de mise en échec
mais ce soir j'ai surtout vécu 1620
moment de partage
inestimable
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vos pensées
merci
[Applaudissements]